hey 42 here if there's one lesson you
need to learn early on in life
it's this whether it's that brand new
cryptocurrency that's definitely going
to be bigger than bitcoin
or a suspiciously large pair of boobs
if something looks too good to be real
it probably is
and yet as the surprisingly large number
of
inexplicably wealthy princes from
nigeria
a country that has no monarchy will
happily tell you
even to this day people still fall for
too good
to be true cons all the time
perhaps the most famous example of a too
good to be true opportunity
is the ponzi scheme in case you aren't
familiar with the concept
let me talk you through it a ponzi
scheme is a kind of fraud that promises
large returns on an investment of some
kind in reality
those returns aren't financed by the
promised investment itself
but by money deposited into the scheme
by
new investors it's a classic case of
robbing peter to pay paul ponzi schemes
are responsible for some of the biggest
frauds in history
and have duped those taken in by them
out of literally
hundreds of billions of dollars but have
you ever wondered why we call them
ponzi schemes in the first place that's
thanks to one
charles ponzi an italian immigrant who
arrived in the united states at the
start of the 20th century
charles ponzi wasn't the first person to
pull off this kind of con
but he was so wildly successful at it
that all future attempts would be named
after him
even today more than 100 years later
ponzi was born in northern italy in 1882
into a once wealthy family that had
fallen on hard times
he was desperate to see his kin elevated
back to the status he felt they deserved
but unable to reclaim the lost wealth of
his ancestors in his homeland
he ended up doing what so many europeans
did in those days
he boarded a ship and set sail for
america
somewhat ironically for a man who would
go on to be immortalized for getting
unimaginably rich
at other people's expense ponzi wasn't
actually very good with money
in fact he was terrible he didn't have
much of the stuff when he set out from
italy
and had even less by the time the ss
vancouver
docked in boston in november of 1903
having gambled away almost everything he
owned in the time it took to cross the
atlantic
in his own words he arrived in a new
world with
2.50 in cash and a million dollars in
hopes unfortunately he soon found his
suitcase full of hope wasn't considered
legal tender in boston
and getting his hands on large stacks of
cash of
what was you know dollars wasn't
anywhere near as easy as he'd expected
ponzi had arrived in america in hopes of
finding the streets
paved with gold but in reality they
turned out to be paved with dishes that
needed washing
road signs that needed painting and
tables that needed waiting
for a man seeking to change the fortunes
of his family
it wasn't going to be easy and that's
pretty much how
ponzi's life continued until 1907
when he secured a job at a bank owned by
fellow italian immigrant
luigi zarasi don't be like charles ponzi
uncover a new industry that has
longevity and potential for huge growth
with the help of trends who've kindly
sponsored this video
if you're a budding entrepreneur
investor or just have
ambitions for personal growth trends is
an absolute
gold mine let me tell you in business
timing and insider knowledge are
everything
and when you subscribe to trends you get
access to a community of industry
leaders in virtually every field
where you can learn how to capitalize on
emerging opportunities
learn growth strategies seo and so much
more
trends also provide regular signals that
tell you exactly what those emerging
markets
are and it's the only place i've ever
found to get that information
the business experts and industry
leaders at trends also publish regular
articles
to teach you how to be better at
business and succeed
no matter what your product is i
particularly enjoyed the trends article
esports
the rise of the next bm off in
competitive sports
i'm amazed at the wealth of information
in this peak behind the scenes at the
business of esports
which is now growing at lightning speed
did you know esports is now a
multi-billion dollar global industry
join the trends community today you can
get your first seven days for just one
dollar
go to trends.ceo forward slash aaron
to get started zarossi's bank was
offering
investors two or three times the
interest rate of its competitors
which ensured a steady stream of new
customers came through the door
each day to hand over their savings and
that was
lucky because zarasi wasn't funding
those generous rates through his own
sound investments he was paying for them
with cash
from newly opened accounts or to put it
another way
he was running a ponzi scheme of course
it wasn't actually called a ponzi scheme
at the time
that would have confused the hell out of
charles ponzi for a start
but the principles were there for all to
see a ponzi scheme is a bit like a house
of cards
the bigger you build it the harder it is
to keep the thing standing
because as soon as new customers dry up
you're in big trouble and it seems the
rossi was well aware of that fact
because
one night he grabbed as much cash as he
could carry
and legged it to mexico in the absolute
chaos that followed
it was ponzi who was left to pick up the
pieces he took care of zorossi's family
it seems the banker forgot to mention
his plans to them while stuffing his
pockets full of cash
and tried to placate the hordes of
disgruntled customers
who'd been taken in by the scam it
wasn't the kind of behavior you'd expect
from someone like
ponzi but as with most of history's
villains
there was another side to the man who
became famous for his greed
ambition and delusion having said that
what ponzi did next would ably
demonstrate all
three of those traits when he went to
visit one of zarossi's former customers
he was briefly left alone in one of
their offices
and there sitting on a table in the
corner
was an open checkbook as far as get rich
quick schemes went
a blank check and a forged signature was
about as simple as it got
and ponzi didn't hesitate he wrote
himself a check
for 423. and 58 cents
a number he hoped would look random
enough to slip under the radar
and walked straight out the front door
unfortunately for him his little theft
was spotted almost
immediately as were the extravagant
purchases he made with his
loot ponzi spent the next few years
behind bars
and when he'd finally served his time
his freedom only lasted a matter of
weeks
before he got himself caught again
trying to smuggle some fellow italians
into the us
all in all it's fair to say ponzi's
plans of bringing
prosperity back to his family were going
rather badly
by 1917 a full 14 years after he'd moved
to the states
he was working as a nurse at a mining
camp with two stints in jail on his
record
and hardly a cent in his pocket but
it was here at his lowest point we got
to see
ponzi's surprisingly charitable side
once again whilst working at the camp a
fellow nurse was badly burnt in an
explosion
ponzi only knew the woman by sight but
when he found out she needed a donor for
her skin grafts
he signed up immediately giving 1 400
square centimeters of skin
from his back and legs skin
is a fairly important organ it keeps all
your insides from
falling out and stuff and ponzi had
given away
rather a lot of it not so much that his
liver popped out but
he did need mumps in hospital to recover
from the ordeal
by 1919 ponzi was fully recovered and
had saved enough cash to set himself up
in a small office in downtown boston he
just
wasn't quite sure what kind of business
he was going to run from it
if you could say one thing for ponzi he
was an incredible ideas man
the only trouble was all his ideas were
but by this point he was desperate
literally writing to companies around
the world
trying to convince them to partner with
him in one of his harebrained
schemes and what do you know eventually
a spanish firm wrote back it was to be a
letter that changed ponzi's life forever
not as it turned out because he'd
finally found someone prepared to do
business with him
but because of a small square of paper
tucked inside the envelope
it was an international reply coupon if
you've never heard of an international
reply coupon
or irc you aren't alone neither had
charles ponzi
but after a bit of research he
discovered the coupon was essentially a
way for
ascender to pre-pay return postage
and it could be exchanged for the
relevant stamps at post offices
around the world ircs had fixed prices
wherever they were sold
but thanks to wild inflation after the
first world war
along with the kind of market craziness
that would make gamestop shares look
stable
the relative values of ircs varied
dramatically
from country to country that meant
theoretically at least
they could be bought in one country then
sold in another
for a profit ponzi had stumbled across
a legitimate business opportunity taking
advantage of prices in one market
to profit in another is known as
arbitrage
and if he hadn't been such a dreamer
he may have even been able to make
himself a tidy little income from it
instead ponzi went big touting the
profit to be made from his international
reply coupons
as the investment opportunity of the
century
and this is where his real genius
finally had a chance
to shine ponzi may not have been the
sharpest tool in the shed
but one thing he had in spades was
charisma
drawing on his italian heritage he was
always immaculately dressed
and he soon discovered a latent talent
for winning people over
and gaining their trust something that
was about to come in very handy indeed
ponzi gave his business a suitably
important sounding name
the securities exchange company and
drawing
on inspiration from his days working for
zarasi
he offered those willing to stump up the
cash a frankly ridiculous
50 percent return on their investment
after 45 days
if ever there was an offer too good to
be true it was this
after all traditional banks at the time
were offering around
five percent annual interest and that's
probably why people were skeptical
at first but a few brave souls decided
to trust the enigmatic italian with
their cash
drawing on all his charm in the first
month he managed to persuade punters to
part with five
thousand dollars a tidy sum in those
days
and more cast and ponzi had ever seen in
his life
and when those early adopters received
their 50
interest payment on time and in full
word of boston's new financial wizard
started to spread like wildfire almost
overnight the name
charles ponzi was suddenly being
whispered on every street corner across
the city
in his second month of trading ponzi
took in 10 times what he'd made in his
first
and a couple of months after that he'd
accepted deposits
of almost half a million dollars as the
money started to roll in
ponzi became seen as boston's prophet of
prophet
the pied piper of paper the all-powerful
monarch of mulan mountain
and the people of boston loved him for
it
he hired salesmen to push the securities
exchange company
to more and more people offering 10
commission on every sale they made
the job was so lucrative his salesmen
hired agents of their own
splitting their commission with as many
subcontractors as they could hire
in under six months some 2.5 million
dollars
had been invested into ponzi's scheme
that's around 32 million dollars in
today's money as
a testament to how legit the whole thing
appeared
it's said that at the height of the scam
75 percent of the boston police force
had invested not that ponzi cared who
the money came from
just so long as it kept on coming he
even
accepted investments from family and
friends
it's hard to believe this is the same
guy who literally donated the skin from
his own back
to a stranger in need people were
investing their life savings into the
securities exchange company
remortgaging their houses and queueing
outside of ponzi's offices in their
thousands for the chance to hand over
every cent
they owned ponzi had spent the previous
15 years of his life
trying to scrape a living together well
when he wasn't in jail
anyway but now almost overnight
he'd become rich beyond his wildest
dreams
he bought himself a 12-room mansion in
the best part of town
and a locomobile which sounds like the
love child of a car
and a train but was basically the 1920s
equivalent
of a rolls-royce he bought diamonds and
jewels
fine clothes and even a bank then
brought his mother over from italy so he
could show her how he'd finally brought
prosperity back to the family
on the surface he had everything he'd
set out to achieve
but behind the scenes things were
starting to unravel
you might be wondering what the problem
was here after all i did say there was
money to be made
in ircs but whilst they could indeed be
arbitraged for a profit
in theory in practice ponzi had
absolutely no idea how to pull it off
the problem was buying ircs in europe
and selling them in the us meant
shipping them across the atlantic
but the cost of shipping what was
effectively a stamp
introduced enormous overheads and the
only way to make the business viable
would have been to transport them
in huge quantities and i mean huge
it was only a matter of time before
someone else figured that out
in the end that someone was financial
expert
one-time president of dow jones and
manager of the wall street journal
clarence barron who'd been hired by a
local newspaper to investigate
the business that was causing such a
stir in town
ponzi had always been secretive about
his business model
but baron was a smart guy he made a few
assumptions
scribbled down some calculations and
concluded
that in order to sustain the magnitude
of investments in the company
ponzi would have had to have traded some
160 million
ircs a quick call to the united states
post office
reveals that only 27 000
were in circulation globally and that
nobody so far as they could tell was
buying them in significant quantities
ponzi was lying so if the securities
exchange company
wasn't arbitraging ircs how was it
making money
you guessed it it wasn't ponzi didn't
actually have to make
many of those 50 interest payments
most of his investors were so happy they
simply reinvested whatever they made
but those that did cash out were of
course paid off
with other investors money ponzi was
running a ponzi scheme
obviously incredibly enough when the
authorities finally figured out what was
going on and raided the securities
exchange company offices
they discovered the business empire
apparently built on international reply
coupons
owned a grand total of 61
of them ponzi had convinced people to
part with hundreds of millions of
dollars
in today's money for nothing more
than a single box of stumps the boston
post published their findings
and as you can probably imagine panic
ensued
for a time ponzi kept the ship afloat
pretending
all was well while sneakily taking loans
from the bank he now
owned to pay out several million dollars
to terrified investors
but when one of his own employees came
forward to reveal what had really been
going
on the game was finally up ponzi's books
were examined
and he was found to be as much as seven
million dollars
in debt whilst his investors had lost a
collective 20 million dollars
around 275 million in today's money
the fallout from the whole sorry mess
was colossal
five local banks collapsed and tens of
thousands of investors were wiped out
people lost everything they had life
savings
houses family fortunes and
there was only one man to blame
considering the absolute carnage he'd
caused
you're probably assuming ponzi went down
for life
and of course he did soon find himself
once again
behind bars but remarkably enough he was
a free man again
after just 3.5 years though admittedly
he did end up back in prison not long
after
when massachusetts brought state charges
to bear
alongside the federal ones he'd already
gone down for the first time
he would remain there for some nine
years though he did manage to get out
briefly on bail during which time he
fled to tampa grew a glorious mustache
and set up a new scam selling swampland
to gullible floridians it seems none of
ponzi's regular stints in prison
did much in the way of reforming him now
that he had a taste for it he would
continue
trying to scam people out of their money
for the rest of his days
so much so he was eventually deported
from the u.s
and sent back to italy where he died at
the age of 66.
considering so many people lost so much
money to the securities exchange company
you might think society would have
learned to steer clear of these kinds of
schemes
now named after charles ponzi or that
strict financial sector regulation would
make these kinds of scams
impossible today but uh
yeah not so much you've probably heard
of bernie madoff
the one celebrated wall street investor
he managed to keep his ponzi scheme
going
for almost 40 years before the scam was
uncovered
in 2008. all told it's thought he
defrauded his investors
out of 65 billion dollars in what was
the biggest ponzi scheme
in history and the largest financial
fraud
ever committed in the us but at least
modern lawmakers seem to have figured
out that this kind of behavior
needs to be discouraged instead of the
handful of years ponzi spent in jail
madoff is currently just over 10 years
into a 150
year term meaning he'll die in jail
unless he lives to be at least 201
and one thing's for sure he certainly
can't afford to be cryogenically frozen
anymore
he owes 170 billion dollars in
restitution to those he defrauded
whilst ponzi is the guy immortalized for
this particular kind of scheme he wasn't
the first to try it
there was zarussi's bank in montreal of
course
but there were others too in 1889
a woman from munich called adele spitzer
ran a ponzi scheme that cost her 30 000
or so
investors 38 million golden
that's close to 500 million dollars in
today's money
and even she likely didn't come up with
the idea in the first place
in fact that honor might just go to none
other
than charles dickens yes that's charles
dickens
he wasn't a con man as far as i know but
ponzi-like schemes did appear in two of
his novels
martin chuzzlewit and little dorit both
written in the mid-19th century
but yeah bernie madoff's infamous
chuzzlewit
dorit scheme doesn't have quite the same
ring to it does it
thanks for watching thanks again to
trent for sponsoring this video
don't forget to check it out using the
link in the description below